okay let's now dig further into the idea
of what government should and shouldn't
be involved in which is a really major
part of the conversation about police
departments we've already talked about
calls to abolish or defund the police in
light of the protests and the killing of
George Floyd there's a bigger question
implicit in that discussion which is
what should governments be involved in
and what shouldn't governments be
involved in and this is a question that
really tracks political views because on
one side you have extreme small
government conservatives and
libertarians they will sometimes go as
far as to say roads should be privatized
you can pay the owner to use whichever
road you want or look for a different
Road another example would be the
privatization of law enforcement where
if you want to be able to call the
police you pay some kind of a membership
fee to the law enforcement company that
you prefer Google cops or Amazon police
or whatever these are extreme examples
but there are some small government
libertarians that believe this stuff on
the extreme other hand you have truly
communist governments where the
government would potentially own all of
the industry and be the sole employer
they manufacture the vehicles the
government employs the doctors owns the
hospitals owns every restaurant decides
what food rations people get and what
farmers need to do with the crops that
they grow these are two extremes we have
no examples of success in the modern
world for either of the two extremes
because like with most things the devil
is in the details this is gray area so
let's dig into it my starting point as a
Social Democrat is that there are many
things government should be doing
instead of private industry but we
should be able to articulate a
compelling reason for why the government
should be involved instead of private
industry so in other words government
should not be the only provider of a
good or service unless there is a
specific case about why they should be
one of the most important things that
governments should be doing in
industries where they are not
participating is setting the ground
rules which I call regulation
I don't need government providing for
example car insurance but I do want
government saying to private businesses
if you want to be in the market of
offering car insurance here are the
rules you have to abide by similarly I
don't want the government running
Airlines and making the airplanes but I
do want government heavily involved in
saying if you're going to build
airplanes here are the ground rules if
you are going to sell tickets to fly
people around here are the ground rules
you need to adhere to now most examples
are pretty easy to get agreement on for
example very few people believe the
government should be the sole
manufacturer of mobile phones and we've
got plenty of companies Samsung Apple
and others that are innovating in that
space and making mobile phones and
that's fine but we'll get back to mobile
phones because there are complexities
that come in when you introduce
externalities which justify the role of
government now on the other hand most
people do believe that government should
be responsible for police departments
and law enforcement missile defense
defending the country from a foreign
attackers stopping terrorism etc and as
I mentioned in the other segment you
might think that it's a good idea to
leave something like human trafficking
to nonprofits and community groups but
this is stuff with such a massive legal
infrastructure and it's so big and
wide-ranging
I do want a properly functioning
government law enforcement apparatus to
be dealing with something like human
trafficking correctly so the small
government versus big government ideas
are very often theoretical they're about
principles but you've got to do way more
work to really figure out how our
economy should be organized health care
is something I want government more
involved in health care there are
examples from all over the world of
government being involved in health care
and a health care being better health
care is an exception as I mentioned we
need a compelling reason to say this
should be pulled out of for-profit
markets when we're talking about
people's health I don't believe at a
moral level that that should be
something subject to the whims a
companies looking to make profits so as
a social democrat i would say healthcare
meets the requirement to be pulled out
of for-profit market-based and then
you've got gray area so like i don't
need the government running all the
hospitals or employing all the doctors
necessarily but maybe I just want them
being the insurance company negotiating
prices establishing ground rules okay
that that's something that that I would
want let me give you another gray area I
want the government doing lots of
infrastructure spending I want them
improving our airports and our roads and
our bridges I don't need the government
running the construction companies or
being the construction company and
buying the bulldozers and the skid
steers and doing it all themselves I'm
fine with government hiring private
industry to do the actual infrastructure
work the problem is when the process of
hiring private industry becomes a crony
capitalist snow job where the jobs are
given to the president's friends so I'm
a social democrat I do think that
markets when they actually are well
regulated and function fairly direct
resources where they are most useful
from a utility point of view and
sometimes we have to say this area of
society should not be subjected to the
market calculation of where the most
utility is derived health being one of
those examples I don't believe for a
second this BS that we hear about
industries have incentives to regulate
themselves government doesn't need to
regulate because if the business does
something bad the PR will be terrible
news reports about them will make them
lose money just doesn't work doesn't
work consider a company that makes cars
and they pollute and harm some town
that's downwind and people in that town
get way more lung cancer over the twenty
years after the cars have been
manufactured that's an externality now
you could say well the bad PR of people
hearing about that is going to make
fewer people buy that company's cars and
so the company has an incentive not to
pollute in order to keep selling more
cars and avoid the bad PR just doesn't
happen these externalities are only
often loosely assignable to
specific action by a company often times
even if the company gets sued it is
cheaper to pollute and kill a bunch of
people and every once in a while you
just pay some civil lawsuit so the point
here is the externalities are not
properly dealt with by markets and that
is the role of government regulation so
the takeaway is I want most areas of
life operating in well regulated markets
with the profits properly taxed to
ensure that everyone has a decent
standard of living
I want industry to operate in a market
with enough safeguards and
infrastructure and it is not to their
advantage to hurt people in order to
earn the profits that they are earning
that's why the regulation has to be
strict enough and in some cases I
actually want the government
participating in the market rather than
just regulating it health care being an
exception an example of that so this
stuff is complex the principles people
who talk about liberty and
non-aggression and they just want to
talk abstractly they often don't want to
do or aren't able to do the difficult
work of really digging into the
specifics and you have to do it in order
to really get anywhere on this stuff
we're gonna continue talking about this
on the david pakman show instagram page
at david pakman show make sure you're
following us there